[Applause]
welcome to swipe here's what's coming up
for you on this week's show Alex goes
for a spin in a car that can read his
emotions I'm at a London art gallery
where the owner will only let you pay in
crypto currency and alyssia's taking
down nerdy ganti now games review that's
also come for you after a quick look at
some of the tech news headlines that
grabbed our attention this week do you
remember the major competition that was
due to give twenty million dollars to
the first privately funded team to make
it to the moon by the end of March this
year well after a decade of hard work
it's over and nobody's won google lunar
xprize Chiefs released a statement
blaming difficulties of fundraising
technical and regulatory challenges so
the grand prize will go unclaimed u.s.
phone chip maker qualcomm has been fined
872 million pounds for paying Apple to
exclusively use its chips the European
Commission has said the payments to
Apple meant no rival manufacturers could
challenge Qualcomm in the market no
matter how good their products were the
Prime Minister Theresa May is launching
a fake news rapid response team the unit
will be based in the Cabinet Office and
will reportedly monitor social media to
identify and challenge Jason for May
and a dad who inspired by his own son
created a hydraulically operated digital
prosthetic arm for babies and toddlers
has made the shortlist in a competition
to find the UK's best new inventors
others in the running for the inventor
prize include the creator of support
seating for young wheelchair users with
automatically adjusting inflatable air
cells and a business that's developed a
Braille in e-reader the winner will get
50,000 pounds to further their projects
we'll talk about what I'm doing here at
a fine art gallery in Mayfair in a
couple of minutes because first up Alex
has been behind the wheel of a car that
researchers claim can read your emotions
and it might just be the flashiest car
we've ever had on swipe you'll see what
I mean moving can be one of the most
thrilling and stressful things we do so
what if your car could kick out on your
emotions or this one can so from the
front looks more or less like an
ordinary car but if you join me around
the side you'll notice across the
windows of these panels now these
contain almost two hundred thousand LED
lights and around and underneath the car
are 110 LED strips now what these do is
display on the outside of the car the
inner emotional state of the driver and
they do that using this heart rate
monitor and what's called galvanic skin
response measuring how much eyes the
driver I'm sweating behind the wheel for
calling this their buzzed car designed
to recognize the thrills experienced
during stunt driving and to display
these through the LEDs
so under the watchful eye of an
experienced stunt driver
I couldn't resist giving it a go you
didn't go out did you and after a bit of
a shaky start
I was off this maneuver is called
drifting over steering to lose traction
and slide the car sideways the car
recognized the thrill I experienced and
litter
[Music]
[Applause]
we stream the data of what the body is
doing the non conscious response
emotional response of the body we stream
that to a mobile phone you would use
everyday a standard mobile phone and 200
times a second we collect all this data
about the body and what you're doing and
that's sent to our cloud API where we do
all our heavy lift lifting our
algorithmic processing to detect what
the emotion is and then in a fraction of
a second that emotion is pulled out from
the data we've sent up and it's sent
straight back to the car where the
gaming PC in the back of the car
produces all the visualization by
looking at the fifth inning in our brain
thought are by no means the only major
manufacturer developing technology in
this field visions of the future are now
full of cars that know their drivers
intimately you may want to slow down
just a little bit no thank you it in any
car the most unreliable component is the
driver we know that because accidents
are mostly caused by human error and in
any way that we can gauge how the driver
is reacting what sort of mood he's in
how he's reacting with a car if we can
do something about that and put checks
and balances in I think it has a serious
purpose in the future so as our cars get
smarter get to know us better reading
our emotions could become the norm
still people will probably prefer if
some of those feelings aren't displayed
in brightness Alex Morgan
Sky News now let's talk about invisible
money here at this gallery in London's
Mayfair
you can only buy items in the latest
exhibition using digital currency like
Bitcoin a little bit earlier I spoke to
the gallery's owner and I began by
asking her why she's chosen crypto over
cash anybody who's been watching the
markets recently we've had a Bitcoin
jumping all over the place and this is
largely due to panic people feed off
rumor for as long as the curse remains a
speculative thing people will continue
panicking and selling so there has to be
mass adoption there has to be they have
to be more businesses more individuals
using
cryptos for everyday things tell me how
much one of these paintings were cost in
real money 75 grand and what's that in
Bitcoin it's all 10 bitcoins are to do
swoop so the value of the paintings the
cost is always fluctuating you do this
and you're happy with that I adapt to it
we agree in in some ok and we have to
achieve that self cryptocurrency has no
central body like the pound has the Bank
of England the way money works it's
really quite sad that suddenly we have
this economy where there's a possibility
for everybody to to make money for many
people to get rich and this is where the
government's want to come in and curb
that they don't like the idea of
ordinary people getting rich because you
know money is really available for the
few it's an enclosed Club but this is
what opens it this is what allows people
to just become a part of an open economy
and to get rich but a lot of those
wealthy people are the only people who
could
this kind of our work at the moment army
Wellness there's the also we offer
fractional ownership whereby if one
person cannot buy a piece of art maybe
ten people can buy the same work of art
alone there are more than 1,400 listed
crypto currencies but elisa only accepts
a handful at her gallery with a
preference for bitcoin cash so what are
we looking at here
this is just some of my holdings I mean
it's very simple because you have a
public address which is a little bit
like accountants or called is it mainly
high net worth individuals that use
cryptocurrency absolutely I mean you see
more institutional investments we see
more people who want to diversify their
portfolio today who already have money
buy into practice but this gonna start
that woman like techies used to blow
they weren't motivated by money there's
been a lot of talk of a bubble in the
crypto space I don't think it's a bubble
to be honest with you I've never felt
that because if it was a bubble that we
have lived through many of them in the
crypto space when you have this
fear-mongering in the press a lot of the
time it's actually attacked it's done on
purpose so that very change was lowered
and institutional screen you can buy in
at a lower price for those people who
don't own any cryptocurrency
why should they care if you like the
idea of our if you like the idea of
making decisions or being in control
learn about this new economy this is the
greatest thing since the intimate
staying with the virtual now it's
videogames time here's Alicia with her
review of some of the latest releases
[Music]
monster hunter 12 is part of a
long-running series that started way
back in 2004 where you take the role of
a hunter who goes around across loads of
different worlds slaying monsters it's
kind of in the name monster huntin world
is a really really great place to dive
in if you've never experienced that loop
before if you've never played a monster
hunter game now it's easier than ever to
play with your friends online and you
can do it on PlayStation on Xbox and
soon it's gonna be coming to PC it's
really well crafted it's really cleverly
done and if you're looking for a game
that doesn't hold your hands I really
recommend picking up Monster Hunter
world Dragon Ball Z is one of the most
iconic action anime series out there so
it really makes sense that you could
turn it into a really well-crafted
fighting game there are just four attack
buttons in Dragon Ball Z so things are
fairly simplistic the complexity here is
in the fact that you can control three
characters at once with 24 characters in
total on the roster if you're looking
for really tough deep fighting gameplay
here you're not gonna get it and dragon
bull fighters probably isn't your thing
but if you're a really big fan of Dragon
Ball Z as a franchise as a series then
this is a really great place to jump in
and a really good introduction to
fighting games in general
lost fear is an ode to JRPGs otherwise
known as Japanese role-playing games and
it comes from the studio he made last
year I am set Sina you play as a 16 year
old boy could katana who returns home to
find that white folk has eaten away at
his hometown if you've played a Final
Fantasy game in the 90s you'll find a
lot of things that are familiar here
it's a really great nostalgic trip down
memory lane but if you're looking for
something that brings in more modern
aspects of JRPGs you're not gonna find
it here but it was perfectly charming
that's it for this week's show don't
forget to follow us on twitter at sky
news swipe if you don't already and join
us again next week for more swipe bye
bye
[Applause]
you